à cause justement d'une rétention
volontaire d'informations par les
dirigeants de nissan et par le procureur
eh bien j'ai été victime d'un système
qui visait à me trouver coupable sans
même donner la possibilité de me
défendre je tiens à prouver mon
innocence je tiens à avoir ma réputation
rétabli je n'ai pas fui la justice j'ai
fui l'injustice et la persécution la
persécution politique
j'ai plaidé mon innocence j'étais alors
menotté restreint et j'étais donc elle
liée là j'avais des poings liés
j'étais sur le point d'être détenu en
isolement
je venais de passer noël seul en
isolement et je n'avais pas parlé à ma
famille depuis six semaines
neuf mois sans pouvoir voir et ma femme
vous imaginez le courage
carole bien évidemment son passeport a
été confisqué son téléphone et son
ordinateur également elle n'avait pas lu
n'a rien de me contacter mais elle a
quitté le japon parce que justement elle
avait peur d'y rester mais quelques
semaines plus tard et bien elle est
revenue au japon elle est revenue au
japon elle a rencontré le procureur le
juge et puis elle est repartie est
aujourd'hui sous mandat d'arrêt neuf
mois après son retour à l'avant vers ça
et c'était la première accusation mais
voilà monsieur quoi nous avaient fêté
l'anniversaire de l'alliance à
versailles oui d'accord mais bon
versailles c'est plus louis xiv versa et
c'est le site le plus visité au monde
c'est un symbole le symbole du génie
français le symbole d'ouverture au monde
un symbole de la mondialisation de la
france
toute entrée tout touriste qui vient en
france ira à versailles ils sont attirés
par ce château par les jardins et c'est
pour ça que l'on a souhaité fêter l
alliance du groupe à versailles ce
n'était pas parce que je voulais me
prendre 10 14
c'est n'importe quoi ici vous avez la
facture de la réservation de la salle à
versailles oui nous sommes bien sûr des
sponsors de versailles des mécènes
versailles a besoin du soutien des
grandes entreprises pour la maintenance
du bâtiment et donc bien sûr
l'alliance a soutenu un grand nombre
donc de rénovation a apporté son soutien
financier pour un grand nombre de
projets à versailles nous avons donné
jusqu'à plus d'un million d'euros la
contrepartie effectivement lorsque l'on
investit 1 million d'euros dans les
rénovations est bien c'est que
versailles nous approuvons assez de
temps en temps de pouvoir utiliser des
salles versailles pourquoi je remercie
mes donc c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous avons pensé à versailles pour
célébrer l'anniversaire de l'alliance et
versailles était tout à fait prêt à le
faire alors qui est derrière chrysler je
vais vous donner des noms qui fait des
parties de secours
alors bien sûr saikawa hay nahda
également et ou pas mais il ya aussi
d'autres personnes on les membres du
conseil d'administration de toyota
faciliter les liens entre nissan et les
autorités même si sa kawa uchida ce sont
des toyota ce sont les principaux
instigateurs bien sûr il ya d'autres non
mais je fournirai directement la liste
aux personnes concernées
te écoutez moi quelques pas le 19
novembre 2010 2018
j'ai senti c'est comme si j'étais décès
détruit le vivez chaque jour en lisant
finalement j'ai une vie tout à fait
réduite mais je sais pas s'il allait
revoir les gens viennent ces plongées
dans un système que je ne comprenais pas
c'est comme s'ils étaient morts dans les
camps donc passer par une période comme
ça vous vous êtes paralysé vous êtes ne
dirais pas hypnotisée si vous êtes dans
bon nombre n'ont anesthésiée voilà vous
êtes un essai vous investissiez parce
que vous n'avez vous protéger contre la
france a beaucoup investi donc vous
allez 16e ont su profiter de la musique
ont supporté des soucis particuliers
soumis au supplice du portier plus les
photos parce que quelque part vous ne
voulez pas regarder cette grotte façon
de survivre
cette période quand j'ai vu que j'étais
sorti
c'est comme si quelque part je revenu à
la vie